[Music]
we have to talk a little bit about dune
we have a whole lot of dune fans out
there so what has the experience been on
that project thus far especially with a
director like Denis it's what I always
wanted to work with him but partly
because he's such a wonderful man but
also because he's a brilliant director
and he's he's a filmic it's it's it's
it's fun when you get one of those big
sci-fi movies and it's going to you know
it's going to be directed by a truth
filmmaker it's not going to be directed
by the studio and they it seemed like
they were giving him pretty free hands
and you have to because his personal
stamp on the film is paramount for the
success of it so I had a lot of fun
doing it but I but it was but I had
seven hours in makeup every day because
I had to be really fat so it was hard
walking away from it what do you think
it is about his rendition of dune that's
really gonna you know capture the hearts
and imaginations of a wide audience
because it is not an easy book to adapt
no it isn't but and his is what he's
really good at is creating this strange
atmosphere with his imagery and and this
cinematic poetry that his is his
trademark and that will will add so much
richness to to the pretty simple story